people think walls separate us but they
also protect us it's two weeks after we
finished insurgent and we've been told
that there was life perhaps beyond the
wall Tristan her group for all those
guys little expedition to see what's out
there
Trista's journey in this film is about
who she can trust she's more comfortable
and confident in herself and she has
been in the past which is on many hands
a very good thing on the other hand can
lead to her being impulsive and not able
to listen to other people there's no
turning back triscuits wooed by the
charm of Jeff Daniels and the world
around him Tris isn't open to the
dialogue that four is trying to have
with her in the truth of what he's
witnessed within this new world they
both disagree kind of on a fundamental
level and they go they're very different
parts I hope it's a great perspective in
seeing Trish's triumphs and trusting
certain people and then the downfalls
and pitfalls and trusting other people
David is not the person that you think
he is if you look at like the technology
in this movie it's meant to take place
in the future but all this technology
exists now the aircraft's the drones the
sensation of you know living in a
virtual world odd how art is mimicking
life at the moment these are things that
were not so far from now it seems like
people are already messing with you know
choosing the sex of their baby or the
color of their hair or their eyes the
other concept is a kind of timeless one
purity versus the concept of someone
being damaged and the idea that there's
no such thing as purity you know all
humankind are complex being so who were
damaged in some way driving for
perfection is impossible I think that's
a very slippery slope so it's
interesting to see someone's
interpretation of how that could affect
society in the future why are we going
home
I think it's very well suited to the
imax experience in the sense that it's a
big visually the scope of the movies
large and also the ambition is large
this time we get to see the world
through a very different lens where
we're leaving the construct of the
Chicago than we're going outside to
discover a completely different world
than a place filled with new characters
and new information we have a very good
visual effects team I think that's a lot
of what this world is and I think that's
what people are looking forward to when
they're reading in the book Robert did a
very good job of bringing these worlds
to life go go go go go I think that the
wall sequence in general on the imax
screen is gonna look incredible there's
these characters who are literally
climbing hundreds of feet vertically and
then once they get over the wall and
they see what the world looks like it's
damaged and host nuclear war to see that
on a screen that's so in your face will
look pretty dynamic the colors it's very
rich shooter done
I would want to see it in at imax
theater because you feel it the rumbling
and whatever is happening you actually
feel it feels very tangible where are
you going we're saving the city the imax
theaters are so fun and i think this is
a visual feast and perfect for that
forum you ready yeah it's a kickass
movie some good action and big set
pieces the bigger the screen the better
for a movie like this pull up
you